we'd like to thank audible for
supporting pbs
it can happen a million ways maybe you
lost your job and had to choose a
utility charge to ignore
or maybe you've developed a serious
health condition and now you're stuck
with a whopping medical bill
or maybe you just forgot to change your
address and a bill went to the wrong
place
at some point in your life you might
find yourself having descended to
another world
known as debt collections and you
wouldn't be alone down there in 2019 the
cfpb reported that more than one in four
americans
have a debt that's currently in
third-party collections
but there are actually different levels
to this world with different opponents
and obstacles to face
that each require a different set of
strategies to make it through with your
dignity and finances intact
so today we're going to be your personal
guides to the
four levels of debt collection
[Music]
this whole situation probably began when
you pass the 30 days late mark on paying
a death or a bill
at which point they probably sent you a
notification which you may have ignored
or
missed welcome you've now entered the
first
level of the debt collections process
technically your lender can report this
late payment to the credit bureau
right after you pass the 30-day mark but
many will continue to give you grace for
an extra 30 days
this is a critical juncture where you
have the power to stop your dissent
believe it or not your lender wants to
have a good relationship with you
fighting you by putting your debt
further down the levels of collections
is costly
so being proactive and upfront with them
is the best way to go
ideally the moment it becomes clear you
can't pay a bill when it's due
call them explain the situation you
might be able to get on a plan and
prevent yourself
from sinking lower once you pass the
60-day mark
things start to heat up you might get
one of those notifications on your phone
from a credit tracking service
telling you your credit score has
dropped by as much as 100 points
that's also when you'll start getting
calls and more letters trying to collect
the payment
let's think of this as level 1.5 because
during this time you're most likely
dealing with the original creditor
and while your credit may have taken a
hit there's still a very high chance you
can negotiate directly with them
once you get to the point where your
debt is 90 to 180 days late
you have crossed the river sticks and
are solidly in the second ring of
collections hell
the original lender has written you off
as a lost cause and
charged off your account if it hasn't
already your credit score is going to
tank
and you'll probably start getting some
aggressive phone calls from
new people this is because many lenders
will bring in a third party collections
agency as a middleman
their aim is to get you to pay as much
as possible as
fast as possible it's not uncommon for
the person on the phone to earn a
commission
between 25 to 45 of the amount you pay
hence the urgency you might sense in
their voice but remember it's not too
late to negotiate your balance down
experts say it's not uncommon to end up
settling for 30 to 70
of the original balance so start your
negotiations with a small amount and see
how flexible they are
also here's a pro tip call them at the
end of the month
most collectors work on monthly quotas
and they may be more a minimal to a
deeper discount as the end of the month
approaches but don't make them any
offers until you have received
a debt validation letter collectors are
required to send these within five days
of initially contacting you
and it will detail what the debt is and
how much you owe
make sure to check these against your
records you don't want to pay a debt
that isn't yours or to a company that
can't
actually prove they own it you also
don't have to go through this process
alone
once you're past that first level of
collections reaching out to a non-profit
debt counselor can be an incredibly
helpful move
especially if you have lates with
multiple lenders
these situations can get very tricky and
the rules can change
depending on your specific situation it
might not even cost you anything
all agencies certified by the national
foundation for credit counseling will
offer free credit counseling sessions
after the 180 day mark the bank medical
provider or credit card company may
give up trying to collect through the
collections agency phew you're off the
hook now right
probably not instead of writing off your
debt as a total loss
they will often sell your debt to a debt
buyer hoping to make a little of their
money back this means you've arrived at
the third and often
final level the realm of debt buyers
these companies will bid to buy bundles
of bad
debts at a steep discount for example if
you had a thousand dollar debt that was
sold to a debt buyer
odds are they only paid 20 or 30 bucks
for it
debt buyers only expect to collect three
to six percent of the balances they own
so keep that in mind as you negotiate
again low ball first and see where it
gets you
and be sure not to give them personal
information
up front let them tell you what they
have on you
this can protect you against shady
collectors and con artists
you also need to be careful about
reviving an old debt that's past the
statute of limitations
collectors have a limited window of time
in which to sue you for your debts
depending on the state
here in texas it's only four years from
the date of your last payment
so if a collector can convince you to
make a payment on a debt that's three
years and 11 months old
the clock resets so i know what you must
be thinking
wow i can just wait it out a few years
and my debt will go away
and yes some old debts will fall off
your credit report after seven years
but remember your credit score and
history are constantly being checked by
utilities rental companies and even
employers
so unless you plan on not making a
single move
in living or employment situation for
the next seven whole years
you should attempt to deal with it debt
buyers can often be
the toughest and most aggressive in
their communication
be sure to review the fair debt
collection practices act so that you
know what they are
and aren't allowed to do calling you
late at night
contacting family members or threatening
you with a rest are all strictly
forbidden
debtor's prison is not a thing anymore
you cannot be thrown in jail for a debt
and if you ask them to stop calling you
at work they're supposed to respect that
request
if a collector is violating these rules
you are entitled to submit a complaint
to the cfpb website
and your state's attorney general's
office sometimes though
instead of ending up with a debt buyer
the original creditor can choose
to take you to court since they'll have
to pay an attorney
they're unlikely to do this over small
balances but
if you ever do find yourself on the
receiving end of a summons
do not ignore it not showing up to court
means that the other side wins
automatically and will have the right to
do things like garnish your wages or
seize assets at this point it's best to
seek professional
legal advice there are organizations
that will provide legal aid to debtors
for little to no cost
again speaking with a local debt
counselor is a good place to start
as you can see the landscape of
collections changes depending on the
level you find yourself in
so it's important to adjust your tactics
accordingly and remember
the lower you go the more likely
collectors will benefit from preying on
feelings of shame and confusion
don't give them the upper hand by losing
your temper playing loose with the facts
or being afraid to ask for help
that way you can beat the heat and claw
your way back to the surface
and that's our two cents we'd like to
thank audible for supporting pbs
audible's selection of audiobooks
includes audible originals
audio titles created by storytellers
from around the literary world
for example thicker than water by tyler
schultz
gives listeners a whistleblower's
account of the theranos saga one of the
biggest financial scams in modern
history
and while we're at home a good night's
sleep is essential for keeping our mind
and bodies
strong but it's not always an easy thing
to get especially now
audible created audio experiences that
let you
meditate with diddy drift off with nick
jonas
bathe in sound with sarah oster and more
you don't need to be a member to access
audible sleep to learn more
visit audible.com forward slash two
cents or text
two cents to 500 500.
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy
click the link in the description to
become a two cents patron
have you ever dealt with a debt in
collections tell us about it in the
[Music]
comments
you